shocking new CBP data revealing that
border patrol Al agents have released
more than
900,000 migrants into the us this year
including a
staggering
155,000 in just September alone on top
of that border patrol Chief Jason Owens
confirming that on average agents arrest
some 47 people with quote serious
criminal history iies per day Brandon
Jud is the president of the national
board of Patrol and he joins us now
thank you so much for joining us Brandon
so what tell me how you would Define
serious criminal histories for our
viewers those are individuals that have
committed crimes against other persons
here in the United States that that
could be up to murder it could be rape
um it could be assault those are the
serious crimes that we're talking about
when you're looking at 47 people per day
that's what we know of because that's
what we apprehend but you also have to
consider that there's about a thousand
people per day that are able to evade
apprehension so we don't know who those
people are we don't know what those
criminal records are we don't know if
they're coming from countries that want
to do us harm such as Syria Afghanistan
usbekistan we just don't know who those
individuals are so when you look at 47
people this is a very serious issue for
every single United States citizen
because these individuals are being
released and they're going through
throughout the entire United States
they're not staying on the Southwest
border I'm just so curious because you
know it was I think it was wrong when
Joe Biden opened our border and reversed
all of the Trump era border policies
that I think were keeping our our
country safe and and keeping legals out
we have data now to prove um that there
were no known terrorists zero captured
um I think in 2019 or or 20 and then and
and then now we're at record numbers we
know Chinese spies are coming over as
well they've they some of them have been
caught but our Terror level has never
been higher our threat has never been
higher than right now and so I'm trying
to understand you know maybe you had
some you know Democrat political reasons
to open the Border uh you know but at
this point it's criminal to put the
country at risk like this why do you
think that even right now at this moment
he hasn't reversed these
policies everything is based upon
politics his litmus is how many people
is he going to be able to drive to the
to The Ballot Box he knows that if he
goes against that base of supporters
that wants an open border he risk not
having them to vote for him in the next
presidential election so everything that
he does is strictly based upon politics
he doesn't necessarily care about the
Safety and Security of the American
people he cares about what his own
personal Ambitions are and that's really
upsetting to every single border patrol
agent that's out there we put that
uniform on every single day we go out
there we Patrol the Border we want to do
what's best for the American people and
we would hope that we would have a
president that would want to do the
exact same thing unfortunately he
doesn't want to but Brandon this is
increasingly unpopular even with
Democrats so I'm trying to understand
the Electoral component um unless he
plans to turn all of these illegals into
voters at some point so it it is a a
very important issue for Democrats that
are in the middle but when you look at
the Hard left when you look at the base
those are the people that want the open
borders they don't care
how much uh chaos has caused in the
United States they strictly want people
to come here you know you hear all the
time uh Democrats say well these people
aren't coming here they're not going to
be able to vote uh because they're
they're in the country illegally and
that's not necessarily that's not
necessarily true all you have to do is
look at what DC just did in in local
elections you can be illegal and you can
vote in local elections then of then of
course when you look at it when if they
come here and they're illegal and they
marry a United States citizen now they
have a spa sponsor for that citizenship
which will ultimately lead to be able to
vote down the road that's that's again
it's all about politics for the
Democrats and that doesn't serve our
country yeah well you also have all
these male mail ballots which um
increases the chances of fraud but I
tell you what Brandon you have a
terrorist attack um and I think a lot of
those electoral Ambitions that the
Democrats have will fall apart because
um it this the danger we're in is
clearly out there feet Brandon John
thank you for joining us this morning
really appreciate it good to be with you
Rachel thank you you got it I'm Steve
duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis